هاي سيري
مع انتقالي نائله عام 2023 تستعد منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي لمجموعه جديده من
التغييرات على خوارزمياتها ولكن في
البدايه لابد ان نتحدث عن الذكاء
الاصطناعي
اندهشنا من الانجازات العبقريه للهندسه
وبرمجه الروبوتات التي تبدو شبيهه
بالانسان فقط
حتى تصبح هذه القدرات اذكى منها جميله
او حتى جبتيه كيف يساعدك كتابه التقرير او
حتى تسميه التوضيحيه لوسائل التواصل
الاجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
او الافتراضيه في النهايه بمعظم الاعمال
التفصيليه نيابه عنا المعلنين سوف يكرهون
هذا بالطبع انهم لا يرجعون اي شيء من
الروبوتات
[موسيقى]
ومع ذلك فان وسائل التواصل الاجتماعيه
المدعومه بالذكاء الاصطناعي ستاتي بوقت
اقرب مما كنا نعتقد فبحلول نهايه عام 2023
سيغيروا الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل جذري
استخدامنا للشبكات الاجتماعيه
لصباح العربيه ريتا سليمان واشنطن